in the last video I showed you what a
neuron looked like and we talked about
the different parts of a neuron and I
gave you the general idea of what a
neuron does it gets stimulated at the
dendrites and you know the stimulation
we'll talk about in future videos on
what exactly that means and that that
impulse that information that signal
gets added up if there's multiple
stimulation points on various dendrites
it gets added up and if it meets some
threshold level it's going to create
this action potential or signal that
travels across the axon that travels
across the axon and maybe stimulates
other neurons or muscles because these
these terminal points of the axons might
be connected to dendrites of other
neurons or to muscle cells or who knows
what but what I want to do in this video
is to kind of lay the building blocks
for exactly what this signal is or how
does a how does a neuron actually
transmit this information across the
axon or really how does it go from the
dendrite all the way to the axon before
actually even talk about that we need to
kind of lay the ground rules of or a
ground understanding of of the actual
voltage potential across the membrane of
a neuron and actually all cells have
some voltage potential difference but
it's especially relevant when we talk
about a neuron in its ability to send
signal so let's zoom in on a neurons
cell so let me just zoom in let me just
zoom in right there I could zoom in on
any point on this cell that's not
covered by a myelin sheath I'm going to
zoom in on its membrane so let's say
that this we go down here let's say that
this is the membrane of the neuron just
like that that's the new membrane this
is outside outside the neuron or the
cell and then this is inside inside the
neuron or the cell now you have sodium
and potassium ions floating around I'm
going to draw a sodium like this sodium
is going to be a circle so that's sodium
and they're positively charged ions have
a plus one charge and then potassium
I'll draw them is little triangles so
let's say that's potassium symbol for
potassium
miss Kay it's also positively charged
and you have them just lying around
let's say we start off both inside and
outside of the cell so let's let me draw
some potassium I'll just do it as a
triangle and when it shouldn't be time
signs should be plus so there's some
potassium inside the cell and then
there's some potassium outside there's a
plus charge and then there's some sodium
inside the cell they're all positively
charged sodium inside some sodium
outside now it turns out that cells have
more positive charge outside of their
membranes then inside their membranes
there's actually a potential difference
that if the membrane wasn't there
negative charges would want to escape or
positive charges or positive ions would
want to get in so let me write this down
the outside ends up being more positive
and we're going to talk about why more
positive and we could say less positive
less positive so this is an electrical
potential gradient right if you if this
is less positive than that if I have a
positive if I have a positive charge
here it's going to want to go to the
less positive side it's going to want to
go away from the other positive charges
it's repelled by the other positive
charges likewise if I had a negative
charge here I want to go to the other
side or positive charge I guess would be
happier being here then over here but
the question is how does that happen
because I left to their own devices the
charges would disperse so you wouldn't
have this potential gradient somehow we
have to put energy into the system in
order to produce the cyst this this
state where we have more positive on the
charge on the outside than we do on the
inside and that's done by sodium
potassium pumps and I'm going to draw
them a certain way so I'm going to draw
them like this and this is obviously not
how the protein actually looks but it'll
give you a sense of how it actually
pumps things out so let me draw it like
I'll draw that side of the protein maybe
it looks like this and you'll have a
sense of why I drew it like this so that
side of the protein or the or the enzyme
and then the other side I'll draw it
like this it looks something like this
and of course the real protein doesn't
look like this you've seen me show you
what proteins really look like they look
like big clusters of things hugely
complex different parts of the proteins
can bond to
different things and when things bond to
proteins they change shape but I'm doing
a very simple diagram here and what I
want to show you is this is our sodium
potassium pump in kind of its
inactivated state and what happens in
this situation is that we have these
nice places where our sodium can bind to
so in this situation sodium can bind to
these locations on our enzyme or on our
protein and if we just had the sodium's
vine and we didn't have any energy go to
the system nothing would happen it would
just stay in this in this situation on
the actual protein might look like
something crazy you know it might the
actual protein might be this big cloud
of protein and then your sodium's you
know maybe your sodium's bond there
there and there maybe it's inside the
protein somehow but still nothing's
going to happen just when the sodium
bonds on this side of the protein in
order for to do anything in order for it
to pump anything out it has to be a take
it has to it uses the energy from ATP so
we you know had all those videos on
respiration and I told you that ATP was
the currency of energy in the cell wall
this is something useful for ATP to do
so ATP that's you know the Dino sign
triphosphate it might go to some other
part of our of our enzyme but in this
diagram maybe it goes to this part of
the enzyme I'll do it in different color
so that's maybe our ATP and in this
enzyme it's a type of ATP ace
and when I say ATPase it breaks off a
phosphate from the ATP and that's just
by virtue of its shape it's able to
plunk it off when it plunks off the
phosphate it changes shape so let's
write this down so let me write down the
steps just so we remember and I think
it'll help so step one we have we have
sodium ions and actually let's keep
count of them we have three sodium these
are the actual ratios three sodium ions
from inside from inside the cell or the
neuron they bond to pump which is really
a protein that crosses that crosses our
membrane now step two we have also ATP
ATP gets broken into ADP plus phosphate
on the actual
and that that changes the shape so that
also provides energy energy to change
shape change pumps shape pumps shape now
this is when the pump was before now
hour after hour pump might look
something like this maybe I'll draw it
let me clear out some space right here
I'll draw the after pump right there
clear that out and so this is before
after the 80 the the phosphate gets
split off of the ATP it might look
something like this instead of being in
that in that configuration it kind of
opens in the other direction so now it
might look something like this and of
course it's carrying these phosphate
groups they have positive charge it's
carrying those phosphate groups and it's
open like this this side now looks like
this
so now the phosphates are released to
the outside so they've been pumped to
the outside remember this required
energy because it's going against the
natural gradient you're taking positive
charge and you're pushing them to an
environment that is even more positive
and you're also taking it to an
environment where there's already a lot
of sodium and you're putting a more
sodium there so you're again going
against the charge gradient and you're
going against the sodium gradient but
now I guess we call it step 3 the sodium
gets released outside the cell so here
and when the this changes shape it's not
so good at bonding with the sodium
anymore so maybe these could become a
little bit different too so that the
sodium can't even bond in this
configuration now that the protein has
changed shape due to the due to the ATP
so step 3
the 3 is na pluses sodium ions are
released are released outside released
outside now once it's in this
configuration we have all these positive
ions out here these positive ions want
to get really as far away from each
other as possible to actually probably
be attracted to the cell itself because
the cell is less positive on the inside
so these positive ions and in particular
the potassium can bond at this side of
the protein when it's in this I guess we
could call it's you know this activated
configuration
so now I guess we could call it step 4
step 4 we have two sodium ions bond two
I guess we could call it the activated
pump activated or changed pump in order
we could say it's in its open form so
they come here and then when they bond
their reach changes the shape it reach
angels of this protein back to this
shape back to that open shape now when
it goes back to the open shape these
guys aren't here anymore
but we have these two guys sitting here
and in this shape right here all of a
sudden these two divots or you know
maybe they're not divots they're
actually things in this big you know
cluster of protein they're not as good
at staying bonded or holding on to the
sodium so these sodium's get released
into into the cell so step 5 the pump
this changes shape of pump so pump
changes shape to original changes shape
to original changes shape to original
and then once we're in the original
those two sodium ions released released
inside inside the cell we're going to
see in the next few videos why it's
useful to have those sodium ions on the
inside you might say well why don't we
just keep pumping things on the outside
in order to have a potential difference
but we'll see these sodium ions are
actually also very useful so what's the
net effect that's going on we end up
with a lot more we end up with more more
sodium ions on the outside and we end up
with more potassium ions on the inside
but I told you that the inside is less
positive than the outside but hey these
are both positive out carry what if I
have more potassium or sodium but if you
if you paid attention to the ratios that
I talked about every time we use an ATP
we're pumping out three sodium's and
we're only pumping in three or only
pumping in to potassium right we pumped
out three sodium's and 2 potassium each
of them have a plus 1 charge but every
time we do this we're adding a net 1
charge to the outside
three on the outside two to the inside
we have a net1 charge we have a plus-one
to the outside so we're making the
outside more positive especially
relative to the inside and this is what
creates that potential difference and if
you actually took a voltmeter voltmeter
measures electrical potential difference
and you took the voltage if you took the
voltage difference between that point
and this point or more specifically
between this point and that point if you
were to subtract the voltage here from
the voltage there you will get minus 70
millivolts minus 70 millivolts which is
generally considered the resting voltage
difference the potential difference
across the membrane of a neuron when
it's in its resting state so in this
video I kind of laid out laid out the
foundation that of why and how a cell
using ATP using energy is able to
maintain a potential difference across
this membrane where the outside is
slightly more positive than the inside
so we actually have a negative potential
difference if we're comparing the inside
to the outside positive charge would
want to move in if they were allowed to
a negative charge would want to move out
if it was allowed to now there might be
one last question you might say well gee
you know if this kept happening if we
just kept adding charge out here our
voltage difference would get really
negative this would be a much more
negative than the outside you know why
does it stabilize at minus 72 they
answer that question we're going to
these are going to come into play in a
lot more detail in future videos you
also have channels which are really
protein structures that are that when
they're in their open position will
allow sodium to go through them and
there are also channels that are in
their open position would allow
potassium to go through them I'm drawing
it in their closed position and we're
going to talk in the next video but what
happens when they open but in their
closed position they're still a little
bit leaky they're still leaky they're
still leaky and they say the
concentration of potassium becomes too
high down here you know and too high
meaning well you know when they start to
reach this threshold of minus 70
millivolts or even better when the
sodium gets too high out there a few of
them will start to leak down the
concentration gets really high and this
is really positive just because of the
electrical potential some
then we'll just be shoved through so
it'll keep us right around my knee - 70
millivolts and if we go below maybe some
of the potassium gets leaked through the
other way so even though when these are
shut if it becomes too ridiculous if we
go to minus eighty millivolts or minus
90 millivolts
all of a sudden there'd be a huge
incentive for some of this stuff to leak
to leak through their respective
channels so that's what allows us to
stay at that stable voltage potential in
the next video we're going to see what
happens to this voltage potential when
the neuron is actually stimulated